[Musique]
benoît hamon le porte-parole du parti
socialiste est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous la crise
de la zone euro la réponse franco
allemande en attendant celle de
l'ensemble de l'europe la récession qui
sera toujours là évidemment après la
présidentielle vont nous occuper au
cours de cette émission benoît hamon
samir tounsi de la fp puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat nous
rejoindrons tour à tour d'abord votre
réaction à la décision de la cour de
cassation pour qui le procureur philippe
courroye a bien enfreint la loi sur la
protection des sources journalistiques
dans l' affaire bettencourt avec donc
les écoutes de deux journalistes du
monde votre votre réaction on va
attendre maintenant que la justice fasse
son travail qu'elle décide du sort de
monsieur courroye qui manifestement
a traité avec un zèle particulier
cette affaire qui mettait en cause à la
fois le gouvernement même si la famille
bettencourt et le choix qu'il a fait 2
demandé des réquisitions contre des
journalistes en violation de la loi et
notamment du secret de protection des
semences monde que globalement ce
pouvoir a été très très loin quand il
s'est agit de protéger les siens en
l'occurrence le gouvernement qui était
directement mis en cause dans l' affaire
woerth bettencourt et ne sommes pas à
mon avis au bout de nos surprises dans
cette affaire vous avez des informations
aucune je dis que nous ne sommes pas au
bout de nos surprises je pense que si le
gouvernement a été si loin c'est
manifestement que les intérêts qu'ils
avaient à protéger étaient considérables
quel sort réservez vos à philippe
courroye ou non lui souhaiter vous
aujourd'hui de faire son travail mais
j'observe que derrière tout ça il y
avait aussi des décisions qui relevait
de l'administration et de probablement
du ministère ministre de l'intérieur
lui-même puisque le dgpn la dcr y
étaient impliqués dans cette dans ces
décisions là donc au plus haut sommet de
l'état des fonctionnaires qui sont
intimement liés à claude guéant lui-même
intimement lié à nicolas sarkozy avait
choisi
et bien d'aller d'abonder dans le sens
d'une surveillance des journalistes on
voit donc l'obsession qui est celle de
ce pouvoir à neutraliser tous les
contre-pouvoirs et compris à les
neutraliser au point de connaître leurs
sources
et bien été jusqu'au viol de la loi et
donc il est démontré ou quasi démontré
aujourd'hui que ce pouvoir ne
s'embarrasse pas de la loi ou du respect
de la loi quand il s'agit de défendre
ses intérêts vous en ferez un thème de
campagne
c'est un thème du gouvernement sarkozy
c'est un thème de la gouvernance sarkozy
le lait le mélange des genres la défense
des intérêts privés l'utilisation des
moyens de l'état pour défendre des
intérêts privés c'est hélas une
caractéristique du mode de gouvernement
de nicolas sarkozy ce qui est clair
c'est un des engagements de françois
hollande c'est que notre objectif à nous
est de redonner aux contre-pouvoirs
démocratiques le rôle qui doit être le
leur dans une démocratie moderne aaron
donc sur nicolas sarkozy selon son
conseiller henri guaino et pas besoin de
faire haro et la fumée c'est pas moi qui
était à la place de monsieur courroye
quand il a fait ses réquisitions il
était grand était procureur il a
lui-même décidé d'enfreindre la loi donc
c'est pas moi c'est monsieur courroye le
dgpn et le dg des séries messieurs
péchenard monsieur soir ce n'est pas moi
qui était à leur place est ce que je
sache donc ces faits sont aujourd'hui
avérés donc ya pas de haro sur nicolas
sarkozy que nicolas sarkozy s'explique
ce serait mieux à lui aussi il doit
s'expliquer si c'est assez logique dès
lors que tout ça le sera proche qu'on
aime considérablement nui peu ya des
fusibles j'entends monsieur guéant peut
jouer le rôle de fusible mais moi je ne
crois pas au fait que un directeur
général de la police nationale agisse de
sa propre initiative sur des affaires
aussi grave que celle là son aval
politique surtout pas sous nicolas
sarkozy je n'y crois pas une seconde
très bien retourné qu'à vos critiques
envers le chef david benoît mondou mais
c'est pour ça que vous êtes ça pourrait
recueillir 1
selon son conseiller henri guaino sans
nicolas sarkozy oui sans le chef de
l'état français est bien l'europe se
serait effondré à plusieurs reprises
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ce
jugement c'est le thème classique de son
moi ce serait pire
issue de cette le registre qu'à utiliser
régulièrement nicolas sarkozy qui
consiste à agiter la peur de l'avenir
pour justifier qu'il soit encore en
place et qu'ils puissent continuer à
donner des coups de boutoir au modèle
social français au service public si je
ne le fais pas ce sera encore pire et ce
sera ça aurait été pire s'il n'avait pas
été là je trouve que ces faibles comme
argument de campagne si c'est le seul
argument qu'il a à défendre je pense
nous n'aurons pas de mal à le contrer
sur le fond évidemment une haie vigné
une autre politique possible que celle
qui aujourd'hui nous condamne à
l'impasse de lost mais nous le
démontrerons lors d'élections ne trouvez
pas quand même que les efforts de
nicolas sarkozy et angela merkel qui ont
conclu un compromis à l'elysée vous le
critiquez sur le fond est ce que vous
n'estimez pas néanmoins que leur leurs
efforts conjoints pour trouver une issue
à la crise de la zone euro est bien mal
récompensée par exemple par l'agencé
standard and poor ce qui menace
désormais 15 pillant en europe la france
tout particulièrement est ce que vous
trouvez que cette mise sous surveillance
par l' agence de notation américaine est
innocente
que voulez vous je vous dis ils ont
renoncé à s'attaquer à un système dans
laquelle la pluie et le beau temps y
compris les gouvernements aujourd'hui de
la zone euro sont faits ou constituer le
temps les castings comme dans les
politiques par les marchés financiers
vous avez désormais des gouvernements
goldman sachs alors en grèce et en
italie tu es à présent de la banque
centrale européenne goldman sachs ils
ont donc renoncé à s'attaquer à ce
système ce système qui vient leur dire
aujourd'hui quoi c'est pas par un
nouveau traité qu'on résoudra et la
crise de la dette d'une part mais aussi
ce que qu'aujourd'hui pointe
standard and poor's qui a pris son avis
avant le compromis de l'elysée alain
publièrent le revendiquer après je veux
dire qu'elle ne l'a pas qu un point de
quoi la récession qui s'annonce et la
récession y'a quoi à l'austérité dès
qu'on a mis en oeuvre une politique
d'austérité qui s'attaque en clair à la
dépense sociale à la dépense publique au
service public comme seul moyen de
sortir de la crise en pariant sur un
retour de la confiance assez miraculeux
qui serait un retour de la confiance qui
d'un coup viendrait irriguer les marchés
financiers sauf qui a pas de croissance
donc y aura pas de confiance et nous
sommes un circle un cercle qui est un
cercle vicieux qui a été on pourra pas
leur reprocher d'avoir fait leur boulot
anticipé par bon nombre de grands
économistes qui avaient le siège de
stieglitz krugman le nobel d'économie ou
de quelques autres en france aussi halo
fce là encore je lisais une tribune
remarquable de monsieur amable qui est
économiste à à paris 1 qui disaient
qu'ils disent est ce là le cercle
vicieux c'est l'austérité comme réponse
à la crise de l'endettement sauf que
l'austérité sacré la récession et la
récession sacrée loin mais c'est une
panne de recettes locales ont donc du
déficit annuel nous avons donc un disque
de la réponse à la crise de la zone euro
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'austérité mais
c'est d'abord la rigueur et c'est pas la
rigueur budgétaire
c'est exactement pour aller couper les
salaires sont réduits qu'on supprime un
treizième mois que vous allez avoir
moins de retraite que vous allez avoir
moins de services publics que vous
allocations chômage ont diminué quoi
conditionnée aux allocations familiales
quant à m bref vous avez compris que
l'austérité c'est cela et quel que soit
le bout par lequel on prenne ses
politiques en france c'est une
augmentation de la tva c'est la
modification
c'est l'une des multitudes et passionnel
ou impressions mondial s'il faut garder
et vous souhaiter que la france garde
son triple a bien évidemment mais pour
cela il faudra aller plus loin justement
dans la rigueur ou ce que vous appelez
évidemment avec la conséquence pour les
peuples l'austérité que vous vous pensez
que davantage de ce que françois
hollande dit c'est l'austérité nous mène
à l'impasse il ne faut pas l'austérité
il faut demain une réforme fiscale qui
fasse rentrer des sous dans les caisses
de l'état pour qu'il puise meinau en
place une politique de relance mais
sinon il n'y a aucune chance de se
sortir de la crise c'est pour ça qu'à à
la fois voir aujourd'hui
vous parler d'un effort de ma merkel et
nicolas sarkozy corps kanak enfin plus
gros effort que d'autres ils sont
rapprochés un peu un vrai je vous
parlais de capitulation ben oui mais
attendez madame merkel voulait à nouveau
traité elle la madame merkel ne voulait
pas qu'on touche aux statuts de la
banque centrale européenne elle a obtenu
mais l'américaine quand la bce
s'investira sans doute plus massivement
pas de remise en cause ni de son statut
dans les émissions ni dans
l'indépendance elle ne voulait pas de
robes roses pour réclamer par tout le
monde je veux dire le zii économistes
qui est quand même à la bible de
l'économie administrée dix économistes
plaident pour les oraux bonnes elles ne
voulaient pas elle n'en a pas eu elle
voulait des sanctions automatiques
contre les états récalcitrants matière
discipline budgétaire elle les a obtenus
qu'avons nous nous français ont obtenu
une solidarité sans doute plus grande au
sein de la zone euro
manifesté par quoi un peu de convergence
sociale de l'harmonisation fiscale
c'est un l'ordre du jour deux camps les
sanctions ne seront pas directement des
cellules qui courent est juste et sont
avoués d'accord c'est à dire quoi en
fait on vous agite un truc qui serait
terrible et après vous comment vous vend
quelque chose qui est un tout petit peu
moins terrine ou 2 - 2 - douloureux sauf
que aujourd'hui les sanctions seront
automatiques vous savez ce que c'est la
pénalité pour la france 0 2 % du pib' 4
milliards d'euros qu'il faudrait
débourser si jamais on venait empreinte
cette règle là et pourquoi est ce qu'on
sera amené peut-être enfin dans l'air a
enfreint une règle du pacte de stabilité
si demain un gouvernement dit je veux
baisser les impôts sur les pme pour
relancer l'emploi ça me fait moins de
recettes fiscales donc peut-être un peu
déficit
si demain un gouvernement dit je veux
investir dans l'éducation parce que j'ai
besoin d'élever le niveau de
qualification de mes enfants ça fait
plus de budget d'éducation donc un peu
plus ce déficit donc je suis obligée de
passer devant la commission européenne
attendait qui va me donner un permis est
ce que j'ai le droit de le faire ou pas
trouvez vous normal vous que votre
bulletin de vote qui fait élire un
député qui est censé faire le budget et
ce bulletin de vote ne lisent que
quelqu'un qui va soumettre un projet
dont un fonctionnaire européen décidera
si oui ou non il vous est permis de
mettre en oeuvre et bien c'est un recul
démocratique
c'est cela quand il ne critique au
niveau français pour ça que françois
hollande a insisté sur la nécessité de
ne pas abandonner notre souveraineté
budgétaire alors vous avez oublié un
aspect tient dans le compromis merkel
sarkozy c'est l'adoption de la règle
d'or un propos c'est plus pour vous
c'est triple non ça change nous agirons
vous le savez que nicolas sarkozy devant
les responsables de la majorité réunis
en petit déjeuner a dit que le pays
avait besoin d'union
que lui répondez-vous il ya des tas de
voix qu'il a ce désir coéquipiers à
droite pour dire union union nationale
qui prépare un forfait il vaut mieux
qu'elle est tout le monde derrière lui
c'est à dire moi je ne suis pas pour la
règle d'or parce que je vois pas
pourquoi pas la règle d'or on en
viendrait à soudain par un coup de
baguette magique remettre en cause les
turpitudes et le laxisme fiscal de la
droite qui a vidé les caisses de l'état
en distribuant les cadeaux fiscaux si
monsieur nicolas sarkozy t'es sérieux
deux secondes et je vous le dis
solennellement la règle d'or ça commence
par rétablir l'impôt sur la fortune dont
il vient d'exonérer 300 mille
contribuables pour l'exercice fiscal
actuel qu'est ce qui justifie que l'on
se prive de plus d'un milliard d'euros
de recettes fiscales alors qu'on parle
de règles dehors il veut de la
convergence vers le haut taux comptant à
léquilibre aimé qu'il reprenne ses
recettes qui est allé à part auparavant
abonder les caisses de l'état qui
aujourd'hui n'y vont plus voilà donc
c'est juste
c'est comme c'est assez curieux mais
c'est de voir nicolas sarkozy qui parle
de règle d'or est touchant c'est une
union de d'union nationale mais non mais
c'est du carton pâte c'est du toc tout
ça et nous nous disons demain nous
arriverons pouvoir avec la volonté de
mettre en oeuvre une réforme fiscale
nous serons particulièrement économe des
deniers publics et vu 2 devant les
français avec des rigueurs
à faire n'importe quoi avec l'argent de
bakker avec l'argent qui rentre dans les
caisses de l'état c'est assez logique
surtout commencer ça va payer des profs
quand ça va payer des policiers mais il
faut être rigoureux dans l'exercice de
la responsabilité qui est celle de la
puissance publique j'ai perdu
aujourd'hui mais ça dépend ce qu'on met
dedans jeudi leur rigueur c'est si vous
voulez la rigueur sont conscientes rien
12 ans et benoît hamon vous êtes le
porte parole aussi de françois hollande
là puisque vous le citez abondamment
d'idées de la gouvernance qui peut être
applaudie accepté l'ovation des
socialistes allemands tout récemment et
puis il ya quelques semaines l'espagnol
oui mais ce sont des socialistes qui
dans leur pays ont voté la fameuse règle
d'or mais on ne voulait pas entendre
parler et non pas fait ils applaudirent
est tout autant qu'est-ce qu'ils
applaudissent la volonté aujourd'hui de
montrer qu'il n'y a pas qu'un seul
chemin les politiques d'austérité et que
ce chemin que propose aujourd'hui
françois hollande passe par le retour
même en période de crise de progrès
social il est inadmissible
inconcevable pour nous de dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y ait plus de place
au progrès social et que ce soit
toujours les mêmes qui payent une
facture pour laquelle où la facture
d'une dette pour lesquelles ils n'ont
aucune responsabilité
c'est la justice sociale c'est l'idée et
la justice fiscale c'est aussi cinq ont
applaudi à berlin madrid ou ailleurs
mais c'est surtout je le dis un an avant
les élections allemandes un grand espoir
pour la gauche européenne françois
hollande et les spu est ce qu'ils se
fassent passer en france va évidemment
irriguer la scène politique aura bien je
retiens coup parler quand même de
rigueur pour l'après 2012 en cas
d'alternance un benoît hamon alors on va
parler de la campagne électorale samira
tounsi de l'agencé france presse va nous
rejoindre à la campagne électorale qui
donc va se poursuivre on le constate
dans un climat d'angoissé de
découragement d'une large partie de la
population un sondage doit vous alarmer
on découvre que les ouvriers penche
désormais majoritairement pour marine le
pen écho de ce désenchantement et cette
désignation qui domine par exemple à psa
aulnay sous bois où s'est rendu mounir
souci
sur le site psa d'aulnay-sous-bois
l'avenir s'écrit en pointillés la menace
d'une fermeture plane sur les 3600
salariés
al'approche de l'élection présidentielle
ils en sont convaincus la solution ne
viendra pas des urnes je pense qu'il ya
aucun parti qui nous sortira de
l'ornière maintenant je sais pas un
bulletin de vote qui va changer les
choses moi je crois que c'est de toute
façon on va droit vers une explosion
sociale et j'espère que ça arrivera
parce que là c'est pas possible on peut
pas laisser tous et tout dézinguer bab
el had et puis ils ont commencé à me
dire qu'ils vont fermer l'usiné on n'a
pas vu
01 partie pourtant semble conquérir cet
électorat le front national le discours
anti mondialisation de marine le pen
trouve un écho chez les ouvriers avec
plus de 40 2% d'intentions de vote la
candidate du fn culmine dans les
sondages elle surclasse nicolas sarkozy
et françois hollande
c'est pas les ouvriers les années
soixante dix qui votait en faveur du pc
et qui aujourd'hui seraient tentés par
le vote fn c'est pas du tout ça ce sont
les ouvriers les plus jeunes ceux qui
ont ce qu'ils ont vécu la crise qui sont
les plus fragiles et qui eux peuvent
avoir la tentation de voter en faveur du
front national une désaffection gênante
pour la gauche et les partis de
gouvernement le ps peine à retrouver les
mots qui touchent les ouvriers au risque
d'une rupture avec cette ancienne base
il ya une tentation dans certains partis
politiques finalement de ne plus
construire l'offre électorale en tenant
compte de ces populations
les 7 millions d'ouvriers reste un
réservoir de voix considérable mais si
le front national fait une percée dans
cette population
le premier réflexe de cet électorat
volatil reste l'abstention massive en
moyenne au moins un ouvrier sur trois
bouts de les urnes à chaque scrutin
donc c'est donc nous a rejoints pour l'
agence france-presse sa mère bonjour
benoît hamon prônons vous avez vu ce
reportage
françois hollande va précisément demain
ou au creusot à la rencontre des
ouvriers que doit-il dire pour tenter de
récupérer l'électorat ouvrier que vous
avez perdu depuis longtemps déjà parce
que c'est un sage
moi je prends cela très au sérieux
très très au sérieux même parce que ce
que ça dit du scepticisme des ouvriers
mais des employés du lui la plupart des
français qui appartiennent aux classes
moyennes il y avait du bulletin de vote
en gros ça sert plus à rien fait crise
ou pas crise moi il m'arrive toujours la
même chose et c'est toujours les mêmes
qui ont les fesses bien confortable dans
les bons coups ç'a en velours d europe
cet ep est sale quand on apprend
désormais qui à la famille peugeot est
une des principes des familles les plus
riches française dont la fortune fiscal
est exilé en suisse tout ça est assez
amusant on peut en faire un fin de la
parenthèse je le prends très au sérieux
je pense que françois hollande d'être le
candidat de la production
le candidat de france qui retrouve un
outil industriel qui redonne toute sa
valeur à ce que la production la
production de la richesse et le fait que
nous ne sommes pas condamnés est un
économie de services on ferme les usines
pour expliquer que tous les travailleurs
et tous les ouvriers vont être reclassés
dans l'économie de services dont je ne
sais pas quoi d'ailleurs canderel la
production pour des gens qui rêvent
d'une explosion sociale pour mettre le
système par terre c'est pas un peu
abstrait mais n'a aucune preuve et la
surproduction ça veut dire qu'on
s'intéresse au travail au boulou des
gens au fait que ce boulot leur
permettre d'accéder à la propriété que
leurs gamins et des conditions
d'éducation bonne et qu'on puisse partir
en vacances assez tranquille qu'on soit
protégé contre la maladie et qu'on
puisse faire de ce tard jean que l'on
tire de son travail le moyen de pouvoir
grandir un tout petit peu or aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus le cas d'abord il ya de
plus en plus de précarité les emplois
créés sont de moins en moins au cdi le
moins d'un mois en cdd de plus en plus
en intérim que le salaire que l'on tire
de son boulot est de moins en moins
élevés et au bout du compte même c'est
le sentiment vous parlez des
travailleurs de jeunes deux ouvriers
jeunes et c'est ça aussi mais je veux
dire ce que ce reportage vient confirmer
ce que l'on sent c'est l'impression en
gros que l'horizon bas il est de plus en
plus sur le court terme et qu'on peut
plus se projeter dans l'avenir les
salaires on les entend peu parler des
salaires c'est ainsi quand je parle de
candidats la produisent une c'est que
cette question de la négociation sociale
du partage de la richesse qui s'est
faite de plus totalement détriment des
salaires est totalement en faveur de la
rémunération du capital qui a explosé
dans les 30 dernières années ça c'est
une question sur nous on entend remettre
en cause le dogme le dogme dominant qui
consiste à faire pression sur les
salaires pour lutter contre l'inflation
l'embout ému a dit nous ne pensons pas
et pas plus françois hollande que qui
que ce soit parti socialiste que c'est
la baisse du coût du travail donc pas la
baisse des salaires qu'on sera
compétitif discipline avec la chine
c'est que j'en parle là vont me poser
des questions et on sera compétitive
avec la chine c'est pas comme ça on
pense que c'est par le fait qu'on
investisse dans ce qu'on appelle des
produits de valeur ajoutée dans la
qualité qu'on arrivera à être compétitif
pour ça il faut investir dans l'outil
industriel ça n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
quand nous proposons deux mains qui est
grande banque publique d'investissement
qui fasse émerger une grande filière de
l'énergie renouvelable pour se
substituer à l'électricité produite
aujourd'hui par le nucléaire et qu'ils
ne le seraient plus on va créer des
centaines de milliers d'emplois
industriels mais à côté de ça je ne veux
pas oublier le point qui à côté des
créations d'emplois est centrale c'est
peut-on imaginer dans les années à venir
une un autre partage des richesses en
faveur des salaires cette question elle
sera posée dès la première année dans
une conférence salariale et sociale qui
mettra autour de la table les
partenaires sociaux le gouvernement donc
les syndicats et le patronat et on verra
branche par branche quelle est la
situation il ya des branches aujourd'hui
qui s'enrichissent qui font qu'ils
dégagent de la valeur ajoutée et qui
distribuent cette valeur ajoutée cette
richesse nouvelle essentiellement sous
forme de bonus en dividendes pour les
actionnaires ça n'est pas aujourd'hui
acceptable et surtout en cas de crise
tellement parlé de rigueur et ceux pour
qui on va être rigoureux la oumma ra
rigueur joulane tout de suite ça va être
pour ceux qui s'en sont mis plein les
poches depuis dix ans alors que pour
tous les autres c'est les poches qui
sont les plus riches les plus riches et
qui me convient mais qui peut payer
l'impôt sur la fortune le paye plus ceux
qui ont bénéficié d'optimisation fiscale
au point que plus payer d'impôts alors
qu'ils sont capable de s'acheter et des
grosses voitures et des gros bateaux de
plaisance et des grosses maisons ceux
pour qui c'est très simple quoi qu'il se
passe crise ou pas crise ça change rien
à leur vie pour vous ça la change
peut-être mais eux ça leur change pas la
vie ça change ni le niveau des loyers
qu'ils récupèrent des américains
visez-vous d'affluence en imaginant ça
concerne des dizaines de milliers des
centaines de milliers de français qui
vont mieux aujourd'hui qu'il n'allait
avant la crise et qui se sont enrichis
et pour ceux qui sont les plus riches
comme pour les entreprises qui ne payent
pas d'impôts sur les bénéfices des
sociétés j'ai l'impression que la
croissance des coûts est vrai qu autre
chose c'est comme ça qu'on va mélanger
la viande par exemple c'est peut-être
vous qui ont acheté mais une
augmentation des ventes de 4,4 à audi
porsche etc alors pourquoi vous voilà
des yachts aussi donc comme c'est pas
beaucoup d'enfants - vous ni moi il ya
des gens qui les achètent donc voilà à
ces gens là ça va être la rigueur et la
rigueur dans l'autre sens et terre que
l'on va être nous rigoureux sur le fait
que eux payent ce qu'il doit à la
collectivité une solution qui est avancé
par certains à droite mais aussi à
gauche pour faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses massivement et neutre a
pas que les que les super riches je
pense à la tva sociale
c'est une quelle belle idée ses terres
vous faites pays de la tva tout le monde
c'est à dire que vous la mairie valls
par exemple défendez cette hypothèse là
lors de la campagne à des faux pas
françois hollande est candidat aux
élections présidentielles et ne défend
pas le principe d'une augmentation tout
simplement de la tva dont on vous dit
qu'elle va aider à la lutte contre les
délocalisations
il ya un moyen très simple de lutter
contre les délocalisations c'est de
faire au niveau européen ce que monsieur
sarkozy a été incapable de négocier que
madame merkel le fait de permettre aux
frontières de l'europe nous avons des
tarifs douaniers s'applique aux produits
qui viennent de pays qui ne respectent
pas les normes minimales en terme social
et les normes minimales entame
environnementale ça pique une surtaxe
qui fasse en sorte que leurs produits
leurs majors une taxe de réciprocité
mêmes amis de bon alors elle est dans le
projet socialiste ça s'appelle les
écluses tarifaires depuis des mois et
vous observerez que l'ump critiqué ces
propositions nous traitons de
protectionniste alors soit nicolas
sarkozy en vient à penser que nos
solutions sont les bonnes et
ce qui est bien moi j'en suis ravi ben
tour n'est pas le problème à l'envers
c'est quand on a une bonne idée que les
autres courent après faut pas
m'expliquer que c'est l'ump qui l'a
sorti en premier c'est pas le cas
question c'est l'hypothèse en éclairer
sectorielle temporaire et ça ça aide à
la relocalisation d'activités on va
revenir sur des points très très concret
si vous permettez vous entendez par là
je vous entendez parler de l'impôt sur
la fortune très concrètement faut
remettre le seuil d'entrée à 800000
euros écoutez on va voir sur la réforme
fiscale je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail de la réforme fiscale sous peu
importe vraiment établir à c'est un
grand impôt sur le patrimoine qui à la
fois avec les droits de succession qu'un
responsable socialiste ne réponds jamais
à cette question et pourquoi pas ce que
parce que c'est tout
l'objectif c'est d'améliorer le
rendement de ce type d'impôt c'est de
faire en sorte mais mais pour son ancien
responsable société répond à cette
question qu est ce que ça ne touche la
classe moyenne mais non c'est pas du
tout c'est parce que aujourd'hui je sais
pas vous dire si c'est ça le bon seuil à
partir duquel il faut le déclin s'est
jamais modifié en juin dernier si ça
trouve il sera plus basse à sartrouville
sera plus haut mais nous allons engager
une réforme fiscale qui d'une grande
simplicité on aligne fiscalité du
travail sur celle du cap du capital sur
celle du travail ont fait en sorte
d'avoir un grand impôt sur le patrimoine
qui intègre droits de succession
rétablir l'impôt sur la fortune mais en
fait en sorte que ceux qui vivent de la
rente payent plus d'impôts on met en
place une réforme de l'impôt sur le
revenu qui le rendent beaucoup plus
progressif par la fusion avec la csg le
prélèvement à la source et la création
d'une tranche supplémentaire bref on va
avoir une fiscalité plus clair plus
juste et dans laquelle je peux vous dire
le résultat parce que cette réforme
fiscale sera faite à l'aune de ces deux
critères améliorera le rendement des
impôts sur le capital il fera en sorte
que la fiscalité soit plus juste c'est à
dire que pour une entreprise moyenne
délais mais dès l'exercice 2013 en cas
de victoire sera la priorité françois
hollande a dit la première grande
réforme qui met en place qui va engager
sera pas la seule mais ce sera la
réforme fiscale elle est indispensable
si on veut avoir après une politique est
une politique à la fois vertueux sur le
plan des finances publiques mais aussi
de relance de la croissance macra
semaine on peut un danger pour
production en 2012 fait un drogué pour
pour
pour beaucoup de choses il ose dire les
aspects comment la gontrie mais comment
la contrer en parlant de l'année s'est
rangé mais pourquoi pas moi j'ai aucun
problème c'est pas parce que marine le
pen est contre et que d'abord une
majorité de français aujourd'hui son
cours parce que nicolas sarkozy était
pour contre pour contre moi ça va me
faire changer mais il faut moi j'entre
au nord d'avoir les mêmes convictions
même quand on est minoritaire je fais
pas ça au gré des sondages donc j'étais
paul droit de vote des étrangers il ya
longtemps j'étais il ya dix ans et je le
suis toujours je pense que ce droit de
vote des étrangers aux élections
municipales dont je rappelle qu'il
existe déjà pour tous les étrangers
communautaires qui sont membres de
l'union européenne ce droit de vote pour
les étrangers aux élections locales qui
ne leur permettra pas d'avoir des maires
comme contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur guillon mais ce droit de vote
des étrangers il est soutenu par une
majorité de français qui constate quoi
que leurs voisins au moins autant
intéressé que aux politiques locales au
moins autant intéressé que la vie
associative et la vie locale payent des
impôts locaux bref il est un citoyen
benoît hamon c'est françois fillon en
personne qui va venir ici au sénat c'est
assez exceptionnel de dans l'hémicycle
pendant l'examen du texte de votre texte
pour l'octroi du droit de vote aux
personnes pour empêcher une conquête est
un progrès démocratique mais quelle est
la stratégie politique derrière c'est
comme cela des gens courir après le
front national non vous croyez pas
françois fillon qu après le front
national âgées sans hésitation qu'il
promet mise à un gouvernement qui sur
les roms sur les étrangers en situation
régulière ou irrégulière a pratiqué une
politique est une politique bon chic bon
genre sans doute mais une politique de
stigmatisation et discrimination de
beaucoup de mon compatriote où beaucoup
d'étrangers dû me grey donc c'est sans
doute très bcbg toujours mais son fils
c'est à dire qu'ils n'empêchent pas bon
chic sinon comme on dit ça veut pas dire
pour autant ce soit très joli sur le
fond c'est bah c'est pas très joli ce
qu'ils nous ont fait ça m'étonne pas que
le sale boulot une fois de plus soit
fait par france moyens parce que sa
sincérité quand il estime que le droit
de vote doit rester liés intimement à la
cites à la citoyenneté française
je lui rappelle c'est ce que dit par
exemple jean pierre chevènement qui
explique avoir évalué les volumes
historiques je le rappelle que beaucoup
de maires ont été élus grâce à des voies
de d'allemands néerlandais portugais
l'italien pays avec lesquels il ya une
réciprocité du droit de vote aux
élections les seins d'une citoyenneté
mais nous nous pensons aujourd'hui que
la citoyenneté locale qui ne veut pas
dire que je sais bien ce qu'elle idée de
la nation française c'est que chaque
citoyen est détenteur d'une part celle
de la nation donc le vote est réservée
aux nationaux parce que seuls les
nationaux sont citoyens ces votes là
sont réservés aux nationaux mais la
citoyenneté locale c'est à dire le fait
de décider ou pas bien ici la
construction d'une crèche de pousser à
cela à ce qui est des politiques locales
communales en faveur et bien de du
quotidien à cela je pense que il est
assez normal je suis heureux que les
français et la maturité que françois
fillon n'a pas et ils souci des
conquêtes démocratiques françois fillon
n'a pas il est assez naturel de
l'étendre aux étrangers sous condition
de résidence évidemment et du fait
qu'ils soient là depuis un certain temps
quand alors ce sera un grand débat au
sénat en tous les cas donc que vous
l'avez dit à sa mère donc françois
fillon viendra en personne et la séance
sera présidée par jean pierre bel le
président socialiste julien dray
bataille politique avec la droite échoue
heureux que ce soit françois fillon qui
se sentent herrada et je suis heureux
qu'on ait infligé une défaite politique
au sénat sa meilleure encore une
question encore une zone appelée moins
de françois hollande revient de berlin
s'il est élu président de la république
en mai il aura face à lui angela merkel
au moins pendant trop longtemps 15 - 15
mois quand même
enfin je vous entendez parler angela
merkel obtient tout ce qu'elle veut face
à nicolas sarkozy comment françois
hollande pour être il veut s'y prendre
quelles seraient ses marges de manoeuvre
sont inversés que ça qu'elles soient ses
marges de manoeuvre pour inverser le
rapport de force à l'heure actuelle avec
manon pas compliqué nous au risque de
faire voler en éclats le couple
franco-allemand et l'union européenne
c'est quand même curieux c'est que nous
il est rien je je rentre pas dans une
négociation comme ça comme une sorte
petit être craintif qui va dire oui à
tout et qui va s'entendre dire non ça
tony g c'est au bout du compte de
résultat c'est quoi elle a tout n'a rien
moi je ne sais pas si vous êtes obligé
de dire non un nouveau traité oui à
nouveau traité non pas obligé est obligé
de vouloir la ratification pourquoi ces
calculs politiques c'est qu'il espère
gêner les socialistes imaginez qu'une
décision de cette importance soit prise
par nicolas sarkozy juste parce qu'ils
espèrent nous ennuyer en nous ressortant
mais les socialistes allemands ont fait
si les socialistes espagnols attendait
mais ces dunes c'est de la motivation
est quand même d'une rare faiblesse donc
ce que je crois c'est que voilà il faut
juste défendre ces idées moi les
allemands défendent les leurs nous
défendons les nôtres et quand qu'on
constate qu'on n'est pas d'accord on
n'est pas juste obligé de prendre la
feuille de madame merkel reprendre les
éléments de langage et de s'aligner
dessus vous êtes toujours en bons termes
avec arnaud montebourg vous le voyez
encore assez régulièrement excellents
termes avec un an - gosso bokova tom
gillis d'accord après la politique à la
bismarck d'angela merkel la semaine
dernière cette semaine il veut mettre
les agences de notation hors la loi vous
vous portez rôle de françois hollande
vous êtes d'accord th je pense qu'il a
raison de dire qu'aujourd'hui le rôle de
natation fait un rôle absolument voulu
mettre un moment j'ai dans mon livre que
j'ai écrit il ya pas encore quelques
semaines donc j'ai dit à peu près la
même chose donc oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui elle joue un rôle négatif
pour la démocratie en europe en france
et dans le monde qu'elles se font de
l'ingérence dans les domaines qui
doivent relever de la seule souveraineté
des peuples et là moi je me moque de
standard and poor's moody's et fitch
quand elles me disent quel type de
politique sociale ils sont six à sept
ministres en 2012 vous parle comme ça
les accepter si vous êtes ministre en
2012 encore plus moi je le dira encore
aussi moody's nous explique que je dois
pas faire d'école moi je vais mourir
aucun problème prend l'engagement si on
mai 2012 d'être ministre de continuer
tant les grenats j'espère qu'on aura
gagné les élections présidentielles
avant savoir si le casting du
gouvernement mais changent pas d'avis
l'opposition ne changeait pas d'avis
mais votre fonction quand même être un
peu différente désormais vous que qui
aviez soutenu quand même martine aubry
lors de la primaire de sa part les
insurmontable de passer d'un cru à
françois hollande stern d'une socialiste
social à l'heure mais néanmoins une
position délicate pour vous aujourd'hui
on n'a pas l'impression depuis cette
émission on voit ça avec aïda caire
courage avant d'accueillir perrine
tarneaud
trois ans déjà comme porte parole benoît
hamon le responsable socialiste avait
trouvé le poste pour se faire entendre
seulement depuis les primaires le
théâtre du ps joue une nouvelle pièce
benoît hamon n'est plus le seul porte
parole depuis la désignation de françois
hollande les cartes sont rebattues de
noirmont devra cohabiter avec les quatre
porte parole du candidat la voix de la
rue de solferino devra s'accorder avec
les hollandais tourner la page des
primaires et des petites phrases je ne
crois pas que retrouve au fond ni parce
que le travail sera fait de coordination
je pense que benoît hamon n'est pas le
représentant du candidat françois
hollande il est le représentant du parti
socialiste est une force mais aussi une
force collective les points presse de
benoît hamon aile gauche du ps seront
sans doute moins prisés par les
journalistes point c'est entre le parti
et le candidat la parole de benoît hamon
risques de dérapage permanent sur des
sujets comme l'intégration européenne
l'économie ou encore les accords ps
benoît hamon incarne
la voix du parti socialiste évidemment
ça doit être fait en bonne harmonie avec
le candidat mais il ya des moments aussi
on a notre spécificité peut-être un peu
une détermination changement forte mais
surtout benoît hamon lorgne
l'après-présidentielle
discipline personnelle et discipline de
parti oblige il doit se ranger derrière
celui qui incarne la social-démocratie
et se mettre à disposition s'il veut
devenir député des yvelines et tourner
la page des européennes bonsoir perrine
tarneaud ce plan sans michel juste pour
rebondir sur vos propos avant ce sujet
benoît hamon vous disiez c'est pas
insupportable de passer de martine aubry
à françois hollande pourtant sur rtl le
18 octobre au lendemain la désignation
de françois hollande vous disiez le
problème c'est de savoir comment on se
rassemble derrière françois hollande
sait comment on fait la différence entre
la gauche la droite si on traduit
françois hollande il n'est pas
clairement de gauche annoncent les
vitraux non je suis en vie ou non si je
pensais ça il aurait fallu que je
démissionne si je pensais que françois
hollande n'étaient pas clients comme il
vient de le faire manière magistrale sur
la question européenne ya d'un côté ceux
qui sont pour la souveraineté la
démocratie de l'autre ceux qui l'ont
abandonné et c'est assez clair et
d'ailleurs la présidentielle devra
trancher cela c'est quel type de
construction européenne on veut je pense
que ce qui est la force justement je
fais le lien entre le fait qu'il clive
et le rassemblement la force de françois
hollande c'est qu'il vient sur cette
question très précisemment de
réconcilier des femmes et des hommes qui
sont la question du traité costières
européens de gauche ou de droite à voter
oui et avaient voté non et on a un cap
qui est celui de l'intégration
européenne ou le dic ne se fera pas au
détriment de la souveraineté populaire
je pense qu'il fait le lien entre les
deux et moi je
je me sens mais alors là totalement
confortable dans ce qui a été le
discours jeudi magistral de françois
hollande à berlin dont vous vous sentez
aussi confortable aujourd'hui dans vos
habits de porte parole du parti
socialiste a choisi bah oui mais bon et
c'est la démocratie en même temps
heureusement j'étais pour les primaires
j'étais pour cet élan citoyen j'ai pas
je regrette pas ce que la primaire a
produit de débat démocratique de
fraternité sur le terrain et voilà
encore un peu le résultat n'en s'est
fallu passer maintenant maintenant il ya
une bataille si on a toujours dit que la
plus importante états d'âme pour
conserver cette fonction derrière
françois hollande après la défaite de
martine aubry non non non non non eu
pour vous oui c'est ça c'est que ça ne
m'a pas échappé c'est à chercher à vous
encadrez même nicolas
non mais je conçois plus ce mot est
peut-être mais je ne sais pas votre cas
sympa le plus important l'essentiel
c'est la relation que moi je j'ai avec à
la fois françois hollande mais aussi
marc comment voulez vous finissez votre
relation et françois hollande sérieuse
quotidienne d'hier oui bah quand on a
besoin de s'appeler quand j'ai besoin
d'avoir comme avec martine aubry entrave
à l'action directe entre le candidat et
vous il vaut mieux par ailleurs si ce
n'était pas le cas ce serait et puis 4
ajoute donc martine aubry avec laquelle
il qui reste la première secrétaire et
une période une personne totalement
impliqué dans ce que sera les conditions
ce que seront les conditions de la
victoire et puis je travaille beaucoup
avec manuel valls alors c'est drôle
parce qu'on est sur les deux bords va
dire de l' extrême du parti socialiste
oui mais
d'abord frac les deux tirent dans le
même sens pour que la gagne et donc moi
je
suit un fantassin et donc je veux que ça
gagne je veux que françois hollande
gagne donc je me mets au service du
rassemblement et de surcroît je pense
que manuel valls sept responsables
politiques de grande intelligence et
d'une grande capacité de travail et moi
j'aime bien bossé avec les jeux primaire
non mais vous savez quand vous avez
d'abord des copains passé à non mais je
vais faut être sérieux deux secondes moi
je pense que ce type là est un grand
professionnel je suis pas d'accord avec
manuel valls à 12 512 mo sec et
professionnels françois bayrou se
lancent demain officiellement dans la
course à la présidentielle est ce que
vous êtes pour une alliance avec le
modem au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
sur la même ligne que personne ici je
suis pour une alliance avec le modem je
réécoute ce que dit le modem le modem il
est contre le retour de la retraite à 60
ans contre les 60000 prof postes de
profs pour la règle d'or contre toutes
nos mesures ou de progrès social donc je
ne suis pas pour une alliance avec le
modem mais y ait des divergences dit
françois lenglet entre le modem et parti
socialiste y en a il y en aura pour
l'instant c'était surtout un objet
politique non identifié qui
dans le débat politique un jour une
fesse poser à gauche un jour deux tiers
de fesses posées à droite et plus
souvent là que qu'à gauche donc bon
écoutez dit clarifiera il dira ce qu'il
aura à dire front travers autant de la
main non mais françois hollande il est
dans son rôle il est conduit à
l'élection présidentielle si les gens
appellent à voter pour lui doit pas
rejeter la main de ceux qui appellent à
voter pour lui mais après at il parlé de
la création possible de françois bayrou
dans l'équipe de françois hollande avant
un autre je pense qu'on est très loin de
ce moment-là qu'est ce que vous espérez
nous et si ce pas quand je travaillais
votre sourire mais écoutez je regarde la
réalité telle qu'elle
la vie politique française c'est qu'en
général
quoi qu'il se passe
ça finit ses jours 9 je les respecte
mais finissent plus souvent à droite
qu'à gauche on pas longtemps en général
à mouiller le débat du jour à
l'assemblée nationale faute il pénaliser
les clients des prostituées
oui je suis pour moi
pour une raison simple c'est que la
prostitution est une violence faite aux
femmes il faut arrêter aujourd'hui
partir de cas isolés de femmes qui n'ont
pas de proxénètes qui font ça en
maîtrisant et en choisissant leurs
clients la réalité de la plupart des
femmes qui sont des prostituées elles ne
choisissent pas leurs clients elles le
font avec des successions pardon parler
crûment de passe qui les amène à être
totalement
abîmé violentées dans leur dignité leur
intégrité ils se trouvent et la réalité
de la prostitution c'est ça alors on
peut nous raconter des jolies histoires
autour mais la réalité de la
prostitution aujourd'hui en france c'est
cela et le modèle qui m'intéresse c'est
le modèle suédois expérimenté depuis une
dizaine d'années et qui vaut beaucoup
mieux que ces grandes braderies auquel
on assiste dans l'essex enter ou eros
center d'allemagne ou de catalogues jmil
même en période de soldes en solde aussi
les femmes tout ça si c'est ce modèle là
la marchandisation des corps que l'on
veut que ceux qui le défendent le
défendre comme tel mais je pense pas
aussi qu'il faille des prostituées pour
assouvir je ne sais quel irrépressible
libido des hommes vous observerez que le
point commun à la prostitution c'est que
que le prostitué soit un homme ou une
femme dans ce quasi 100% des cas le
client est un homme et il y aura
toujours la demande des clients oui mais
si l'abolition ne pas dire éradication
ça veut pas dire que mais cela étant dit
les résultats de la suède ça montre quoi
c'est que ça diminue et que en allemagne
on voit quoi un développement y compris
la prostitution parallèle et notamment
en direction des mineurs donc si c'est
moi je ne veux pas d'un modèle qui
légalise la prostitution et développe en
plus des pratiques qui sont des
pratiques inacceptables à l'égard des
mineurs dont voilà donc je suis
favorable au modèle suédois et je pense
que cette question des violences faites
aux femmes est une question centrale
dans la société française benoît hamon
vous êtes un élu de la région ile de
france le ps et les verts ont conclu un
accord sur un tarif de transport unique
applicable dès le 1er janvier 2013
l'opposition de droite au conseil
régional dénonce un coût de 500 millions
d'euros pour cette mesure comment vous
allez la financer écoutez madame
pécresse et les dents jusqu'à enregistre
t as qu elle est l est pour la rigueur
budgétaire
absolue quand il s'agit époux tôt pour
faire rentrer de l'argent dans les
caisses de l'état quand on va financer
une mesure qui est une mesure qui fera
sur une concession d'azur nation du
foot rapide et ghislain 98 mais ce qui
coûtera une estrade mobiliser des
ressources supplémentaires
cela étant dit qu'il atteignait alors ça
peut être en partie des entreprises ne
se sera pas on voit pas quel celles qui
ont déjà du mal non on sera le but ce
n'est pas de nous mais nous mais vous
avez raison je sais pas le but n'est pas
d'être en situation par une
un investissement de la région de tahrir
ce que seraient les efforts que font les
entreprises pour pouvoir créer de
l'emploi matern emploi donc nous en
discuterons mais je veux dire juste que
c'est assez curieux que madame pécresse
sur ce double registre différent à la
région deux mois de mai de ministre du
budget est ce que les habitants d'île de
france n'attendent pas avant tout des
trains qui arrivent tout simplement à
l'heure où de nouvelles lignes on
échangera pas la qualité qui prime
c'est pour ça que ce qui était
l'engagement des socialistes depuis le
début c'était de dire que ce ce qui est
le plus important aujourd'hui c'est
qu'un on est d'être un conte nombre
suffisant de qui arrivent à l'heure
trois qu'ils soient de qualité qui soit
une qualité de l'équipement qui
permettent de voyager dans ces
conditions confuses investi ce qui
suppose un gros naze qui ça fait donc
mais ce qui a été discuté dans le cadre
du stif ce qui est des investissements
sont des investissements qui sont
maintenus façon à améliorer l'équipement
d'aider des transports de franciliens
mais nous n'abandonnerons pas la qualité
au motif qu'il faut mettre un autre le
tarif unique tension ile de france le
socialiste jean paul huchon dit qu' il
en a un peu marre d'avoir toujours un
pistolet sur la tempe c'est celui des
écolos est-ce que vous salue et françois
hollande qui lui est attentes là encore
de se dégager de ce pistolet sur la
tempe que lui ont mis les les écolos
avec l'accord sur le nucléaire en trop
depuis yeux pers je crois pas que quand
même c'est ce qui explique les grands
cafouillage
connaissez le désaccord sur un point
c'est le sort de la hague d'accord il
est sain de retraite ont dû fermer knox
ma vie mais bon sur les pressant et de
madre sion mais est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que françois hollande on
est en photo derrière vous êtes un homme
sous pression complètement tétanisé dans
débutant on le dit aussi des aubryistes
tient notamment pour la répartition des
sièges aux législatives un test que tout
ça est parfaitement faux voilà tactile
et qu'il s'ébrouant dans cette campagne
présidentielle sans aucune sans aucune
aux castrais ce lié à ses partenaires la
preuve c'est qu'il a pris avec beaucoup
de sérieux la question de l'accord vers
ps et notamment sur les points qu'ils
pouvaient pour lui poser difficulté le
contraire eût été de considérer que tous
aillent à la géo l'intérieur a
effectivement en tentant à tout prix
qu'elle corrige et oui mais c'est un
monde que l'accord est sérieux autre
dossier sensible en ile de france et
celui du logement et notamment celui du
micro logement et de son coût le
gouvernement souhaitait instaurer une
taxe sur les loyers abusifs dans les
petits logements de moins de quatorze
mètres carrés le scénar de majorités de
gauche à supprimer cette taxe vous
regrettez ce vote
je ne le comprends pas bien
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors dans
l'hémicycle est ici au sénat je crois
que il ya une décision qui a été prise
je ne comprends pas bien aujourd'hui
le sens cette décision parce que voilà
mais je suis réaliste au sénat estime
qu'il s'agit au certain que les cas
qu'il s'agit d' voilà mesures gadgets
wii
président de la commission du
sénat pas échappé mais mme bricq pense
cela j'ai entendu ces arguments je pense
est inefficace mais qu'elle est
inefficace mais il c'était un symbole
porté par toutes les associations de
défense du droit au logement portée par
la gauche et je pense que
je ne
préférais que cette taxe soit d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut corriger l'erreur
je suis pas là pour un township à un
prof qui distribue les bons et les
mauvais points vous me demandez une
position je vous la donne vous êtes un
benoist apparu ministre du logement que
c'est un mauvais coup porté aux plus
fragiles être fascinant franck lui
commence à faire son boulot de
secrétaire d'état
oui mais voilà il commence six mois
avant la fin de son mandat donc quand
ils aiment bien benoist apparu mais je
veux dire quand on voit aujourd'hui le
prix du loyer les prix des loyers la
montée de la spéculation sur
l'immobilier l'absence de taxe sur les
logements vides etc voilà des mesures
qu'il aurait été utile de prendre
el-assad non pas être l'épreuve juste
derrière question de nos hameaux benoît
vous serez candidat aux législatives
dans les yvelines oui attrapé l'encours
beaux-arts si saint-cyr l'école donc ça
s'est confirmé une industrie qui s'était
il faut réparer l'échec des européennes
un an ces gens cette fois dans
l'assemblée nationale benoît hamon très
bien être député mais on verra bien ça
ce sont les électeurs de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines qui le
diront merci à vous merci inc la semaine
prochaine cécile duflot sera l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir
[Musique]